you know I'm always curious about let's
say the practical implications of
scientific research both at a personal
level familial level social level all of
those things you know so I mean one of
the things that I'm planning to do in
the near future is to launch a website
that will enable people to assess
themselves with what we've developed a
scale called the Big Five aspects scale
that breaks the big five down into ten
aspects each of which which provides
some additional high resolution and
useful descriptions of personality so
you'll be able to go there and find out
what your personality is like you'll be
able to compare yourself to other people
who you know to find out where your
similarities and differences are but one
of the things we've been thinking about
doing as well is putting up on the same
site a real IQ test like nicely
validated probably focusing on fluid
intelligence because it's alittle bit
lis less linguistically complex to do so
but maybe measuring verbal intelligence
and then showing people the strata of
occupations in which they're likely to
find maximal success because you know
from for me given that I know that the
people vary in their cognitive abilities
tremendously and that that's actually an
important determinant of their life
outcome it seems to me so let's say
someone tests out in an IQ of around 115
and so you could say look you know
you're pretty damn smart you're you're
up above 85% of the general population
you you could you could probably do a
pretty damn good job as an undergraduate
at university if you're also disciplined
right if you were conscientious you hit
the books hard you're gonna you're gonna
come out in the top quartile of your
class assuming that you're doing at a
spectacularly successful spectacularly
selective University but you're gonna
have a much more difficult time as a
master student and PhD level stuff is
going to be you're going to be pushing
your luck to to really master that but
you know you could be here's a here's a
domain of what would you call it
industrial organizational activity where
you could really be in the top 10
percentile you know it's like so if you
have an IQ of a hundred and fifteen like
you might make one bang-up plumber and
you can have a spectacular
successful career as a plumber and maybe
as a manager of other plumbers and all
of that and you know and I mean I
actually happen to be a real aficionado
of the trade so I certainly don't think
of that as something that's a that's a
low quality or low status occupation in
the least but we would we would like to
tell people okay here's here's here's a
here's an intellectual domain that's
probably too high for you to be
successful without working insane hours
to to to to close the gap because you
can do that with insane work up to some
some limited degree but it seems to me
that the logical thing to do at least in
part is to give people a sense of what
their advantages and limitations are and
then say to them okay well given that
here is a place that you could go where
you could be optimally successful and so
you know that's kind of my take from a
policy perspective let's say but like
what have you thought about you know the
massive diversity and intellectual
ability I mean what are the implications
from a policy perspective as far as
you're concerned well I think vocational
guidance is clearly one I actually did
some consulting and some research for a
nonprofit group called the Johnson
O'Connor Foundation which is vocational
and testing they're not that big on G
but they have the only battery of tests
they bring someone in and do a fun day
of cognitive tests and from that they
give some advice about what kinds of
professions match their cognitive
strengths and weaknesses and I actually
did some brain imaging on their tests
and was very interesting stuff you think
because it's hard to do the
psychometrics properly with regards to
vocational guidance because we don't
really know we don't have a good handle
on how to classify jobs into their
various subtypes like John Holland has
done some good work doing that but but
there's so many jobs and it's hard to
figure out what makes two jobs the same
or similar you know no I was at Hopkins
when Holland was there and some of my
friends were graduate students
for him and I learned all about that
vocational testing it's very powerful
and as you know it's that's more of his
scales that kind of morphed into more
personality like dementia yeah that's
exactly the Nexus that we want to play
out it's like okay because there is a
reason I know people have been mapping
Holland's Hallman's job categories on to
the big five and with a fair bit of
success you know and we're hoping that
the differentiation down to the two ten
levels of personality will provide even
more precision but but with more general
policy like okay so fine so reasonable
vocational counseling that's a good idea
when does it start to start in junior
high like do you do what the Europeans
do and start to track people into trades
and and and higher education at that
kind of early age the Europeans seem to
have had great success with that
so it's certainly Germans in particular
yeah so it's reasonable to look at but
the problem in the United States there
are so many problems with the way we
conceptualize education and the whole
idea of tracking I don't know how it is
in Canada but in the United States this
idea of tracking has a very negative
balance to it you know segregating the
smart kids into one one set of classes
and the less smart kids and others and
then there's remedial education and
there's been a tendency a strong
tendency in the United States to feel
that kids learn from each other so you
don't want homogeneous groups based on
learning ability you want it's so funny
because the people say that with regards
to to let's say academic achievement but
they play exactly the opposite stunt
when it comes to such things as as
childhood sports you know so if they
look at football for example it's like
well hey let's say great likability it's
like you don't have the people who
stumble around on the field dropping the
ball all the time playing with the top
end quarterbacks and nobody thinks
there's a problem with that they don't
say well everyone learns from everyone
else in that situation so to me it
speaks
refusal to admit to the stark reality
that there are massive cognitive
differences between people and to try to
actually start to address that with some
degree of seriousness and the
seriousness should be something like
okay well let's look at the bottom 15%
of the population cognitively speaking
that's like what the hell can we do for
those people that's going to be useful
and you know like the guy that I was
telling you about I was trying to think
of some way that he could find
respectable and productive and
relatively stable position in society
that would be useful and I thought there
was a couple of things he could do like
one of the things he could have done I
think he could have been encouraged
let's say to to collect trash in the
downtown areas like he could have been
assigned a city block and and it could
have been said to him look your job is
to keep this damn city block clean
here's a bag here's the stick you get up
in the morning you go do this it's like
makes everybody's life more pleasant
it's a valuable contribution it's
something you could do with a certain
degree of pride and there's a socially
valuable end of it now what happens in
Toronto is that people drive around
these vacuum cleaner machines on
sidewalks and pick up the scrap paper
and all about it that actually turns out
to be a very cognitively demanding job
because well you have to pay careful
attention you can't run over people you
have to have decent social skills and
you know it's complicated but it might
be nice to see but we but we're not
mature enough to have a discussion like
this as a society we might want to say
is like okay well there's a group of
people who aren't going to be able to
compete in the in the cognitive
workplace they're they're not gonna do
it and there's actually lots of them and
we're not going to say they're lazy and
we're not going to say they're not
looking for work we're not gonna say any
of that we're gonna say look we need to
find occupations that have public
utility that aren't just make work
projects that people of that level of
abstract capacity could actually perform
but I don't think we have the maturity
to have that conversation we don't have
the economics
so I I would go even a little to the
left of you and I would say there's
nothing wrong with making work programs
you know to allow people I mean you have
you know to work with dignity so you
have that option but you also have this
interesting experiment being proposed of
the minimum annual income yeah well that
one worries me because see if there's a
couple of things about that one that
concerns me because you know so we're
having a conversation here where we're
taking differences in IQ seriously but
the problem with the guaranteed annual
income issue I think one of the problems
and I'm not denying its potential
utility it's something I think that
would have to be experimentally
determined you know and all of that and
maybe it could replace a plethora of
less efficient social welfare programs
but you know it isn't obvious to me
it's obvious to me that there's a
substantial proportion of the population
and I would say it's probably five
percent that would destroy themselves
instantly if you gave them a guaranteed
annual income and they would do it
because they're very low in
conscientiousness for example and very
impulsive and AGG I've worked with many
guys often X cocaine addicts who were
often not all that high on the end of
the cognitive distribution but very very
low in conscientiousness high in
impulsivity and those guys were
absolutely fine as long as they were
flat broke but man I tell you as soon as
they had money they were done it was
like three days in the bar cocaine binge
facedown in a ditch and then they were
fine until they got money again and so I
don't the problem with the guaranteed
annual income solution is that you know
man does not live by bread alone let's
say and the if you have money and you
have things to do then you have a life
but if you just have money you don't
have a life